so you said you're not a very good
programmer you're the world's most
modest human being okay but you'll
continue saying that I understand how
this works but you do radiate a sort of
love for programming so let me ask do
you think programming is more an art or
science is it creativity or kind of
rigor I think it's some of each it's
some combination some of the art is
figuring out what it is that you really
want to do what should that program be
what what would make a good program and
that's some understanding of what the
task is with the people who might use
this program want and I think that's
that's art in many respect the science
part is trying to figure out how to do
it well and some of that is oh real
computer science ii stuff like what
algorithm should we use at some point
mostly in the sense of being careful to
use algorithms that will actually work
properly scale properly avoiding
quadratic algorithms when a linear
algorithm should be the right thing that
I'm more formal view of it same thing
for data structures but also it's I
think an engineering field as well then
engineering is not quite the same as
science because engineering you're
working with constraints you have to
figure not only so what is a good
algorithm for this kind of thing but
what's the most appropriate algorithm
given the amount of time we have to
compute the amount of time we have to
program what's likely to happen in the
future with maintenance who's gonna pick
this up in the future all of those kind
of things that if you're an engineer you
get to worry about whereas if you think
of yourself as a scientist well you can
maybe push them over their horizon in a
way and if you're an artist what's that
so just on your own personal level
what's your process like of writing a
program say a small and large sort of
tinkering with stuff you just start
coding right away and just kind of
evolve iteratively with a loose notion
or do you plan and a sheet of paper
first and then kind of
design in this you know what they teach
you in the kind of software engineering
courses an undergrad or something like
that what's your process like I it's
certainly much more the informal
incremental first I don't write big
programs at this point it's been a long
time since I wrote a program that weighs
more and then I call it a few hundred or
more lines something like that many of
the programs I write or experiments for
either something I'm curious about
or often for something that I want to
talk about in a class and so those
necessarily tend to be relatively small
um a lot of the kind of code I write
these days tends to be for sort of
exploratory data analysis where I've got
some collection of data and I want to
try and figure out what on earth is
going on in it and for that those
programs tend to be very small sometimes
you're not even programming you're just
using existing tools like counting
things or sometimes you're writing awk
scripts because two or three lines will
tell you something about a piece of data
and then when it gets bigger well and I
will probably write something in Python
because that scales better up to call it
a few hundred lines or something like
that and it's been a long time since I
wrote programs that were much more than
that
you